歡迎收看泛科學新聞
讓我接著感謝這一百位泛糰會員
在這歲末年終之際
感謝你們選擇支持泛科學
讓我們能繼續在這個荒謬的世界裡
找尋科學的真理
以及下個月的薪水
為了報答各位
以及滿足我們公費吃喝的慾望
我們將在 12 月 30 號舉辦「歲末晚餐直播」
我們會在直播中回答大家的問題
但要提醒大家
請各位會員務必現在 Right Now
移動你的滑鼠或手指
到我們的「頻道會員專屬貼文」下方
留下你想問的題目
因為沒有公開的連結
因此你必須親自點進泛科學頻道主頁
切換到「貼文」分頁
才會看到那個像是 9 又 3/4 月台一樣的
隱藏入口
找到了嗎
沒找到的待會再找
總之 Terima kasih atas sokongan anda.
親愛的老師、爸媽們
你是否正在擔心孩子的教育
跟不上 AI 變化的速度
你的擔心是正確的
因為 AI 實在瞬息萬變啊
因此我們的姊妹頻道 泛科學院
和 YouTube Learning 還有 Google for Education
聯手打造了一套完全免費
專屬於大人的《AI 教學手札》
不用擔心學不會
五位 Google 認證的現役教師
用最貼近教育現場的方式
手把手示範
AI 如何真正落地在教室跟家庭之中
從課堂教學、語言練習、特教調整
到行政管理與評量回饋
清楚易懂、立即可用
如果你需要一套
「明天就能派上用場」的 AI 教育指南
趕緊點擊下方資訊欄連結
這是完全免費的
看完還能考取 YouTube Learning
還有 Google for Education 的聯名證書
別再猶豫
科學家剛剛發明了一種「固態空氣」
跟玻璃一樣透明
卻比牆壁還能隔熱
蛤
讓空氣頓時凝結這你也會
你厲害
因為這真有用
根據統計
全球建築物消耗了 40% 的能源
而窗戶就是那個在冬天放生暖氣
在夏天迎進熱浪的內鬼
過去科學家試過用「氣凝膠」來隔熱
這東西你可能也聽過
它很輕、隔熱很強
但因為內部結構太混亂
光線穿過去會散射
看起來霧霧的
所以人稱白色恐怖
痾不是
是罩雺 tà-bông,Frozen Smoke
但現在科羅拉多大學波德分校的物理學家
在《Science》期刊上發表了一種新材料
Mesoporous Optically Clear Heat Insulator
中文翻譯就是「介孔光學透明隔熱材料」
縮寫叫 MOCHI
對 就是麻糍 muâ-tsî
這不是這個團隊第一次挑戰
「透明隔熱」這個聖杯了
通訊作者
伊凡·I·斯馬柳赫 (Ivan Smalyukh) 的實驗室
之前就做過纖維素氣凝膠
但薄薄一張還行
一旦變厚
還是會因為結構混亂
變得像白內障一樣霧霧的
為了打破「越厚越霧」的魔咒
他們開發了一種精密的「分子翻模」工程
強迫材料乖乖排隊
既然要翻模
科學家需要一個模具
來製造出奈米級的孔洞
他們利用一種「界面活性劑」
就像肥皂分子一樣
在水裡會「自組裝」
自己乖乖排隊
形成無數條極細的「圓柱狀微胞」
就像無數根隱形的「圓柱體鷹架」
接著倒入矽氧烷材料
包覆住那些微胞
形成堅固的骨架
再來是「脫模」
科學家把剛剛搭好的鷹架
也就是那些界面活性劑通通洗掉
原本鷹架佔據的位置就變成了空腔
留下了一個由「中空管狀網路」構成的固體
最後 為了不讓這個脆弱的空心結構塌掉
他們使用「超臨界乾燥」技術
小心地把裡面的液體換成空氣
結果就是一塊體積 90% 以上都是空氣
但卻是固體的透明材料
這個結構造成了一個物理奇蹟
叫做「克努森擴散」
你看 這些管子的內徑只有不到 50 奈米
這數字很關鍵
因為空氣分子平常在傳遞熱能時
平均要跑個 60 到 70 奈米
才會撞到另一個分子
但在 MOCHI 裡面 路太窄了
咬著麵包趕著上學的空氣分子還沒撞到人
就先撞壁了
把空氣原本的導熱能力直接掐斷
數據顯示 MOCHI 的熱導率
只有 10 到 12 毫瓦每米克耳文(mW/m·K)
比「靜止的空氣」還要低
而且因為結構太整齊
透明感不輸新垣結衣
直逼葉隱透
穿透率超過 99%
所以科學家改叫它
「凍結空氣 (Frozen Air)」
而且它不只是超強隔熱盾
這塊麻糍還有第二型態 「熱能黑洞」
MOCHI 對可見光是透明的
陽光進得來
但對於物體發出的熱輻射
也就是紅外線
它卻是強力的阻擋層
可以把熱能「只進不出」地鎖在裡面
團隊做了一個實驗
完全不用任何透鏡聚光
就只是把 MOCHI 蓋在吸熱體上曬太陽
底下的溫度竟然直接飆升到 300°C
這代表未來的窗戶
不只能隔熱
還能變成超高效率的熱水器
也可以用來驅動「熱能製冷系統」
拿來發電開冷氣
目前這項技術已經申請了專利
雖然還在實驗室階段
但能把「透明」、「隔熱」跟「高溫集熱」
這三個矛盾屬性結合在一起
堪稱重大突破
科學家表示 這材料還可以用在服飾
它是軟的
可以彎曲、捲起來
而且只要薄薄一層
隔熱效果就比羽絨衣還強
非常適合極地探險或是太空衣
但記住它是透明的
嗯
終於科學家宣稱他們找到方法
抓出躲在體內的「殭屍細胞」
這對廣大的高齡族群來說
絕對是個天大的好消息
如果你剛好是一隻勞贖的話
研究成果剛發表在《Aging Cell》期刊
蛤 你的確是嗎
那我們繼續看下去
大家都知道細胞太老或受損
通常會自我了斷
但「殭屍細胞」不一樣
它們停止工作了
但拒絕去死
反而變成去死去死團
賴在組織裡
還不斷分泌發炎物質 (SASP)
把周圍健康的年輕細胞也帶壞
是導致衰老和癌症的不良一族
那為何不研發一種藥
把這些殭屍清掉
的確 這就是所謂的 Senolytics 抗衰老藥
但最大的痛點是
要區分殭屍和正常細胞
比區分鍾佳播、孫協志、姚淳耀還要難
通常得把細胞殺死、固定、切片、染色
才看得到結果
而美國梅奧診所這次的突破
關鍵在於製造了
100 兆種不同隨機序列的 DNA
搞一場超大型不良一族尋愛記
先說 這不是電腦模擬
而是拳拳到肉的「濕式實驗」
是貨真價實的 100 兆條實體 DNA 分子
數字看起來很大
但想想國中理化學過的亞佛加厥常數
1 莫耳的分子有 6000 垓個
這 100 兆其實連 1 莫耳的億分之一都不到
所以全部裝在試管裡
也不過就一滴
但這 100 兆個不重複序列怎麼來的
其實 DNA 合成儀就像一條「自動串珠產線」
A、T、C、G，就像是紅、黃、藍、綠
四種顏色的珠子
被混在同一個大桶子裡
機器在串珠的時候
每一步都從桶子裡「盲抓」一顆
連續抓了 80 次
排列組合多達       種
而我們只做了
也就是 100 兆條
因為「可能的組合」實在太大
所以我們做出來的這 100 兆條項鍊
每一條的顏色排序
幾乎註定都是不重複的
他們就是來參加這場戀綜的單身男女
100 兆個 性格都不同
而科學家的目標只有一個
找出那個對「不良一族」有著病態執著的
究極戀愛腦
好 馬上進入第一關「負向篩選」
科學家先準備了兩個房間
一間關滿了經過嚴格身家調查
保證健康的乖寶寶細胞
另一間關滿了人工製造的不良殭屍細胞
把這 100 兆個參賽者推進「乖寶寶房」
如果情不自禁就黏上去
淘汰
第二關「正向篩選」
把這些對乖寶寶無感的
推進不良房
如果還在裝高冷 那也沒用
淘汰
要找的是那些不壞不愛
瞬間戀愛腦發作
瘋狂黏上去
死都不放手的病嬌
經過 9 輪殘酷淘汰
他們終於篩選出代號 6762 的冠軍適配體
這傢伙已經被訓練成「不良單推」
眼裡只有不良
但是 6762 到底被不良身上的什麼給迷上了
科學家趁著適配體
緊緊抱住那個神秘目標時
把這一對「黏在一起的情侶」
從細胞湯裡面拖出來
發現那目標是一種
「纖維連接蛋白 (Fibronectin)」的特殊限定版
雖然纖維連接蛋白在身體裡面到處都是
是細胞外基質的主要成分
就像標準學生制服
但殭屍細胞的版本就是有那麼一點不一樣
上面繡著喧嘩上等、怒羅江門
有種壞壞的特質
重點來了
能抓得到 就打得到
而且適配體比抗體更小、更便宜
未來或許可以把「毒藥」綁在上面
精準攻擊殭屍細胞
但但但 就像開頭說的
研究團隊誠實表示
目前只對「老鼠」有效
他們當然也試過黏人類細胞
結果
完全沒反應
看樣子不良一族尋愛
勢必得開拍第二季
這也告訴我們
如果你還沒找到真愛
不用覺得絕望
你只是需要相親 100 兆次而已
嗯
如果器官被整組挖掉
還能自己長回來嗎
中國首都醫學科學創新中心
與德國德勒斯登工業大學
聯手美國麻省大學醫學院
這次挑戰了生物學的一個鐵律
研究剛剛發表在《科學免疫學》期刊上
看過工作細胞都知道
「胸腺」是免疫系統的軍校
但它很不耐操
年紀大了就會自己縮水
變成一坨脂肪
在我們哺乳動物的設定裡
就算還有點修復能力
也得靠「原本剩下的組織」當作種子
才長得回來
如果把它「整組挖掉」 連個渣都不剩
那在過去的認知裡
絕對是 Game Over 不可能復活
當然這次實驗不是在人身上做
還不是
而是墨西哥鈍口蠑螈
超可愛的六角恐龍
選牠是因為牠連大腦、心臟都能再生
根本是擁有再生能力的祝福者
而且牠小時候的皮膚是半透明的
頭骨也還沒變硬
手術起來很便利
最重要的是
牠的胸腺是三顆獨立的小肉球
不像我們的會跟其他器官黏黐黐 (liâm-thi-thi)
這讓科學家可以非常乾淨、完整地「整組挖掉」
確保之後長出來的絕對是無中生有
而不是靠殘留組織作弊
結果短短 35 天後
遭遇如此創傷的蠑螈
竟然在原本空蕩蕩的地方
「無中生有」長出了一個全新的胸腺
科學家利用「單細胞測序」這個分子放大鏡
去檢查裡面的每一顆細胞
發現不管是用來打仗的 T 細胞
還是負責教官工作的上皮細胞
全部都回來了
結構跟原裝的一模一樣
倍ばい FIGHT 倍ばい 倍ばい FIGHT
倍ばい 倍ばい 倍ばい
FIGHT
但會不會中看不中用呢
科學家乾脆把這個「再生胸腺」
移植到另一隻同品系的蠑螈身上
觀察了整整一年
為了測試功能
科學家還故意切斷了宿主的一隻手
結果發現這個外來的胸腺
竟然能正常運作
持續產出帶有螢光的 T 細胞
而且這些 T 細胞真的聽得到召喚
精準地跑去宿主的斷肢傷口集合
這證明了它不只活著
還完全接管了宿主的免疫導航系統
這到底是怎麼辦到的
科學家原本以為
蠑螈一定是用了跟哺乳動物
一樣的關鍵基因 Foxn1
這傢伙在我們體內可是胸腺的大總管
所以團隊利用 CRISPR 技術
把蠑螈的 Foxn1 基因敲掉
想說這樣再生就會失敗了吧
沒想到再生照樣啟動
只是長出來的版本很迷你
這顯示 Foxn1 基因只是「蓋大樓」的工頭
但「決定要不要蓋」的老闆另有其人
科學家抓到了真正的幕後推手
是一個叫做 Midkine (MDK) 的訊號通路
這個 MDK 在受傷後幾天內會瘋狂飆升
如果用藥物阻斷它
再生就真的停了
這項研究粉碎了脊椎動物
無法「從零再生」器官的天條
而且蠑螈的胸腺在分子層面上
其實跟我們哺乳動物很像
如果未來能模擬 MDK 這個機制
或許我們也能幫免疫力衰退的人
來個胸腺重開機
蛤 胸腺長回來
會不會也長出六根粉紅色的外鰓
你仔細觀察
那個想活到 150 的獨裁者就知道了
不要再騙自己了
用差不多的電腦 跑差不多的模擬
說它差不多的糟 差不多的妙
科學家膩了
這次他們用地球上最強的電腦
跑出了史上最硬派、最真實的黑洞進食秀
這項由普林斯頓高等研究院
跟熨斗研究所（Flatiron Institute）團隊
發表在《天文物理學期刊》上的研究
解決了困擾天文物理學界
幾十年的超難題
泛糰們都知道
黑洞本身不發光
發光的是掉進去的東西
也就是「吸積盤」
但要模擬這個發光甜甜圈超難
你得同時算愛因斯坦的「廣義相對論」
也就是時空怎麼被扭曲
還得算「磁流體力學」
看帶電的氣體跟磁場怎麼互毆
最難的是 你還得算「輻射傳輸」
搞清楚那些光子
是怎麼在彎曲的時空裡亂噴、散射
甚至反過來把氣體推開
為了不讓電腦算到燒掉
以前科學家通常會在這些環節
偷食步thau-tsia̍h-pōo
他們用一種叫做「M1 近似」的方法
把「光」當成一種「流體」水流來算
這就像是你為了省顯卡的效能
把《Cyberpunk 2077》的光追關掉
雖然畫面大致看起來像
但光影細節完全是糊的
方向也是亂猜的
這種偷懶的方法
在面對那種吃太飽、光太強的
「超愛丁頓吸積」
也就是黑洞吃到超過它的消化極限的時候
就會算出錯誤的結果
但這次科學家動用了「Frontier」跟「Aurora」
這兩台世界上第一跟第三的超級電腦
運算能力是電競筆電的幾兆倍
但是要拒絕差不多
有肌肉還不夠 還得換腦
他們使用了一套全新的演算法架構
「AthenaK」
做到了兩件以前做不到的變態細節
第一是拒絕平均值
以前的模型只算光的平均流向
但新模型直接暴力解開
「角度依賴」的輻射傳輸方程
意思是說 他們不只算光往哪裡流
連光從哪個角度射過來
怎麼被彎曲時空掰彎
都一條一條算得清清楚楚
堪稱物理界的全域光追
第二 他們拒絕人工添加物
以前為了省時間
常會偷偷加個「人工冷卻函數」
讓吸積盤趕快成形
但這次團隊堅持「純天然」
直接丟一團甜甜圈形狀的氣體 (Torus) 進去
讓它從零開始自己演化成吸積盤
完全依靠物理定律自然冷卻
結果顯示
當黑洞吃太飽
也就是進入「超愛丁頓」狀態時
以前的模型可能都太差不多了
舊模型常說這種狀態下「輻射效率」很高
彷彿黑洞吃多少飯就吐多少光
根本是永動機
但新的模擬發現
黑洞其實是個浪費食物的屁孩
數據顯示
在超愛丁頓吸積時
例如吃到 150 倍愛丁頓極限
輻射效率竟然掉到只剩 0.5% 不到
為什麼
因為吸積盤會變得很厚、很胖
像個甜甜圈
中間只留一個小小的漏斗
大量的能量沒變成光射出來
而是被強大的「風」跟「噴流」給帶走
或是直接被困在厚厚的氣體裡
連光都逃不出來
最後無奈地跟著氣體掉進黑洞視界
而且這個研究還意外解釋了
「小紅點」 (Little Red Dots)
對 我們最近才介紹過這些韋伯望遠鏡
在早期宇宙中發現的紅通通小點
讓天文學家很頭痛
而根據這個模擬
這可能就是正在暴飲暴食的黑洞
因為吸積盤太厚
擋住了原本該射出來的 X 光
加上外面包了一層又冷又厚的外流氣體
導致我們只能看到能量較低的紅光
還誤以為它是什麼溫和的恆星不忘
殊不知裡面怪獸正在開無雙
當然 再怎麼反差不多
研究也有它的極限
目前的模擬還是「色盲」
只算了光強沒算顏色 (頻率)
而且只模擬了十倍太陽質量的黑洞
但不再差不多的模擬
讓科學家第一次真正進入了
黑洞進食的混亂現場
感覺就像是原本都在看 360p 的馬賽克畫質
突然切換成 8K HDR
那個細節跟震撼度完全不是同一個檔次
除了黑洞 你還想用來看什麼呢
算了 我不想知道
誒 告訴你
有一種方法
可以瞬間加薪 15%
對 聽起來很像詐騙或是心靈課程
或是詐騙的心靈課程
但這不是話術
而是墨爾本大學聯手荷蘭萊頓大學
剛發表在
《社會科學與醫學》（Social Science & Medicine）
上的最新研究
他們試圖幫兩件我們每天都在經歷的事
「通勤」與「在家工作」
貼上一個精確的心理價格標籤
研究團隊使用的是澳洲長達 20 年
追蹤超過一萬六千名員工的縱貫資料
還刻意刪除了 2020 年以後的疫情數據
避免封城、隔離這類極端狀況的干擾
這篇研究之所以重要
是因為它直接挑戰了一隻
學術界的上古神獸
2011 年 Roberts 等人用英國資料
得出一個被奉為圭臬的結論
那就是
「通勤會摧毀女性的心理健康，但男性幾乎沒差」
十多年來 這句話成了
無數職場政策與性別討論的理論基礎
但這次研究團隊決定先拆掉統計學裡
最大的謊言 「平均數」
過去多半只說「通勤平均而言對人不好」
但這篇論文改用「無條件分位數迴歸 (UQR)」
這種高解析度工具
簡單說呢
因為我也只能簡單說
它不看整體平均
而是像斷層掃描一樣
直接檢查心理健康光譜上的每一段人
結果很殘酷也很精準
對那些心理狀態本來就不錯的現充來說
不管怎麼通勤、怎麼加班
心理健康幾乎不受影響
真正被打爆的
是心理健康分佈後段的脆弱族群
先看男性
英國研究裡「沒事」的男人
到了澳洲卻出事了
數據顯示
澳洲男人雖然整天 G'day mate
心理健康卻隨著通勤時間拉長而顯著下降
關鍵可能不在距離
而在交通工具
英國人多半搭火車、公車
可以放空看書
澳洲卻是標準的車輪國家
那種隨時盯路況
得小心澳洲三寶
袋鼠、鱷魚、無尾熊的高認知負載
加上路怒症
才是慢慢燒壞男人大腦的元兇
而且受傷最深的
並不是最憂鬱的人
而是心理健康落在 40% 到 45% 之間
不好不壞的「邊緣人」
單程只要多塞個 30 分鐘
心理健康的下滑幅度 換算成錢
就大約等於家庭收入瞬間少了 2%
那在家工作總可以了吧
答案是 對男性來說真的沒有差
WFH 帶來的好處
幾乎只剩「不用塞車」
對心理健康沒有額外加分
女性的情況跟英國也完全顛倒
研究發現
通勤時間長短對女性心理健康
幾乎沒有影響
研究者推測
關鍵在於育兒制度
相比英國高昂的托育成本
澳洲有較完善、補貼也更豪氣的托育系統
讓媽媽們少了一層
「趕接小孩又怕錢不夠」的慢性焦慮
通勤的殺傷力直接被這層 Buff 給抵銷
但對女性來說 「混合辦公」超讚的啦
研究算出一個甜蜜點
那就是每週約 50% 到 75% 的時間在家工作
對心理壓力較大的女性
在這種模式之下
因為能重新掌控工作與生活的節奏
心理健康提升的幅度
最高可換算成家庭年收入增加 15%
這些百分比不是拍腦袋來的
研究團隊先用迴歸分析
算出一種「心理健康匯率」
他們先問當家庭收入增加 1%
你的心理健康分數平均會上升多少
建立這個基準後
只要某種工作模式帶來的心理健康提升
等同於加薪 15% 的效果
它的「影子價格」就是 15%
弔詭的是
當女性完全在家工作 (100% WFH) 時
這個心理紅利反而消失
甚至變得不顯著
暗示社交隔離或家務與工作的邊界崩壞
會反過來吃掉好處
這篇研究給的結論很務實
但畢竟我們臺灣不像澳洲
該怎麼辦呢
我想還是從基本開始吧
G'day mate
誤會太大了
原來我們的頭髮不是被「推」出來的
而是被「拔」出來的
而且是它自己拔自己
這項顛覆了幾十年來生物學常識的研究
來自化妝品巨頭萊雅 (L'Oréal)
跟倫敦瑪麗皇后大學
剛發表在《自然通訊》上
因為你值得
所以科學家得搞清楚
你的頭髮到底發生了什麼事
我們一直以為頭髮生長就像擠牙膏
毛囊底部的細胞不斷分裂、變多
因為空間不夠
就把老舊的細胞硬是往上「推」
頭髮就這樣長出來了
這聽起來很合邏輯對吧
但因為太合邏輯了
這其實沒有被認真檢視過
科學家這次用超高解析度的 3D 顯微鏡
去偷窺人類毛囊細胞的私生活
結果發現
沒那麼單純
他們發現毛囊裡有一層叫做
「外根鞘 (Outer Root Sheath)」的細胞
雖然嚴格來說它外面還有一層結締組織
但在這群會動的細胞裡
它算是最外圈的參賽者了
它們的動作非常詭異
在集體「往下跑」
而且還是用一種「螺旋」的方式旋轉向下
對 這跟口紅底座一樣
而頭髮就是那根被轉出來的口紅
為了證明這個迴旋力才是老大
科學家把負責細胞分裂的「毛球」部位
直接切掉
甚至用化學藥劑把細胞閹了
如果舊理論是對的
沒有新細胞去「推」
那頭髮應該立刻停止生長 對吧
結果像鬼故事一樣
頭髮還在長
雖然變慢了一點
但它依然頑強地往外鑽
這證明底部的推力不是重點
那重點是誰
科學家接著破壞了細胞裡的「肌動蛋白」
這一次 頭髮生長速度瞬間暴跌超過 80%
這證實了全新的「拉力模型」
頭髮周圍的外層細胞
就像是一顆會動的「活體螺帽」
緊緊咬住中間的頭髮
當它們集體螺旋向下的時候
這股強大的牽引力
就把頭髮像螺絲釘一樣
硬生生的給「旋」了上去
原來我們的每一根頭髮
都是被自己的細胞給「轉」出來的
為了徹底證明這件事
這群生物學家找來物理學的外援
他們把成千上萬個毛囊細胞
看作是一種「黏滯流體」
並套用了流體力學的「納維-斯托克斯方程式」
來進行模擬
在電腦裡跑了兩種劇本
如果假設外層細胞是不動的牆壁
只靠底部推
電腦算出來的流速分佈
跟顯微鏡下看到的完全不一樣
模型嘚嘚
但當他們在方程式裡加入了一個
「移動的牆壁」
模擬外層細胞正在主動向上拉扯時
Bingo 數據完美吻合
別緊張
實驗用的人類毛囊不是拔教授或研究生的
還不是
這些新鮮的毛囊樣本
來自醫美診所的「拉皮手術」
別人不要的鬆弛頭皮
變成了科學家眼中的黃金
這研究除了讓我們知道人體的奧妙
更重要的是
這可能徹底改變治療脫髮的思路
與其拼命刺激毛囊生長
說不定只要訓練這些細胞的
「黃金迴旋」之力
讓它們抓得緊一點
你的髮際線就有救了
就不要再拜託聖誕老人了
蛤
有了頭髮聖誕節還是沒有對象怎麼辦
就像舒華說的
啊你又不是只有聖誕節沒有對象
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想吐槽
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了按讚、訂閱、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼
比六角蠑螈還可愛的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見